1943
detailed information from the manhattan
project was stolen from los
alamos by the russian spy known as
perseus
1968 the vietnam war vietcong soldiers
orchestrated by perseus
attempted to steal an american-made
nuclear bomb from a u.s
firebase five days ago
while on a mission we acquired intel
that perseus is in play again
and planning an attack on the west
[Music]
perseus the cia's analysts consider him
to be the single
largest threat to the free world
mr hudson we're all aware of perseus
we're also aware he's more myth than
fact i mean
personally i think he's nothing more
than the russian boogeyman
general hague allow me to introduce the
man
a suit of the responder cia
clandestine special officer russell
adler
he's one of the few people even come
close to capturing percy's
uh mr adler why should we take this
perseus threat seriously you don't have
to sir
yeah then a lot of innocent people are
gonna die why do you say that
sir every time perseus has come into
play it shifted the balance of the cold
war
after 13 years of silence if he's active
something big is gonna happen
something that will affect the free
world
[Music]
mr president sir mr president mr
president
this is jason hudson and russell i know
their names
who do you think approve their last
mission
is the threat real yes sir we believe it
is
can you stop perseus we can sir i've
already submitted the requisition for my
team
sir their requests are highly irregular
most likely illegal if the press gets
old what the hell are you talking about
you know who we are every mission we go
on is illegal
sergeant woods plausible deniability is
the backbone of our work
al we're talking about preventing an
attack on the free men and women of the
world
give mr adler whatever he wants
gentlemen
you've been given an important task
protecting our very way of life from a
great evil
there is no higher duty there is no
higher honor
and while few people will know of your
struggles
rest assured the entire free world
will benefit i know you won't fail us
pre-order digital copy and get early
access to the open beta and instant
access to the woods operator pack in
modern warfare including warzone
[Applause]
this war was a lie
years of blood just the fuse of a secret
war
[Music]
decades
my fellow americans a nuclear conflict
would well be mankind's last
we want to make this a more peaceful
world
five days ago we acquired intel
soviet agent perseus is in play
if he's active something big is gonna
happen
something that could shift the balance
of the cold war
let's go find the [ __ ]
mr president is the threat real
yes sir we believe it is give mr adler
whatever he wants
[Music]
i know you won't fail us
[Music]
pre-order digital copy and get early
access to the open beta and instant
access to the woods operator pack in
modern warfare including warzone
[Music]
[Music]
so
you